bonsoir à tous vendredi 23 février
bienvenue dans le 7-8 l'hebdo c'est
l'émission de tv soixante dix huit pour
revenir sur l'essentiel de l'actualité
de la semaine
tout de suite les titres de cette
édition c'est la meilleure année
enregistrée depuis dix ans le tourisme a
battu des records en 2010 est en ile de
france les chiffres ont été a dévoilé
hier jeudi par le comité régional du
tourisme 49 millions de visiteurs se
sont rendus sur le territoire francilien
reportage témoin de cette bonne santé du
secteur le domaine du château de
versailles qui a enregistré une hausse
de 15 % de fréquentation l'année 2017
est elle exceptionnelle également dans
le département invités de cette émission
et le débat s'est chargé de
communication pour la mission tourisme
des yvelines et puis l'essentiel de
l'actualité on reviendra sur la ligne 18
confirmer le projet gare bécane relancer
à la verrière et un stage à voisins le
bretonneux pour confectionner une oeuvre
recycler c'est à suivre
l épisode de pollution se poursuit ce
vendredi en ile-de-france depuis
quelques jours la région a subi une
pollution aux particules fines pour
inciter les automobilistes et les
motards à laisser leur véhicule au
garage ile-de-france mobilité a mis en
place aujourd'hui vendredi son forfait
antipollution ce dispositif à 3 euros à
81 vous permet d'emprunter les
transports en illimité et dans toutes
les zones
airparif l'organisme chargé de
surveiller la qualité de l'air dans la
région prévoit une amélioration de la
situation ce samedi la grève des
facteurs reconduite ce vendredi à saint
quentin en yvelines depuis quatre jours
la distribution du courrier est
perturbée sur le territoire à l'appel de
la cgt plusieurs dizaines d'agents sont
mobilisés pour dénoncer leurs conditions
de travail et s'opposer s'opposer au
projet de réorganisation voulue par la
direction 12 postes seraient ainsi
menacés sur le bassin de l'agglomération
selon les grévistes
écoutez leurs représentants au micro de
nicolas kirillovitch tous les deux ans
ont subi des réorganisations qui
supprime environ 10% du personnel
si on pouvait entendre que les
réorganisations était absorbable il y a
dix ans aujourd'hui forte force est de
constater que
les facteurs ils n'arrivent déjà pu à
rentrer à l'heure avant on avait eu le
temps de faire du social on avait le
temps de faire un bien notre travail
aujourd'hui on voit quand on connaît le
côté social qu'on demande aux
personnages et de payer si jamais on ne
veulent que le facteur discute avec eux
du jamais vu depuis dix ans après des
temps moroses l'île de france a connu en
2010 est une année record en termes de
tourisme se chiffrent en témoigne 33,8
millions de touristes sont descendus
dans les hôtels du territoire l'an passé
le comité régional du tourisme a révélé
ca dernière donnée hier jeudi et la
grande couronne francilienne a
grandement contribué à cette belle
reprise sujet devient grand paris disney
le musée du louvre et le château de
versailles
voici le top 3 des lieux les plus
fréquentés par les touristes en 2010 est
en ile-de-france la tour eiffel arrive
en quatrième position
toutes ces destinations sont en
progression
versailles ainsi accueilli 15 % de
visiteurs de plus qu'en 2016 avec 7
millions 700 mille visiteurs la grande
couronne parisienne attire de plus en
plus de touristes
c'est d'ailleurs une des ambitions du
comité régional du tourisme développer
l'offre en dehors de la capitale
on sait que paris est une pépite donc
tout cela nous conforte il n'empêche que
c'est un lieu un lieu d'entrée pour
l'activité touristique dans notre région
de france et vous avez également dans
toute la région ile-de-france des
pépites peu connu mais connues ou
inconnues et il faut les faire en sorte
connaître c'est une des objectifs du
comité régional du tourisme
la région ile-de-france a défini en
novembre dernier 15 territoires
prioritaires en matière de tourisme
parmi lesquels auvers sur oise avec les
impressionnistes ou moins connus encore
comme hier dans l'essonne avec la villa
du peintre gustave caillebotte récemment
restaurée embellie du tourisme en
ile-de-france la grande couronne
francilienne vous l'avez vu qui a
contribué à cette bonne phase pour
parler justement
du secteur dans les yvelines le secteur
du tourisme et le dit bassett avec mon
plateau bonsoir moi ça vous êtes la
chargée de communication à la mission
tourisme du département des yvelines
alors on l'a vu dans ce sujet + 15 % de
visiteurs l'an passé au domaine du
château de versailles et 7,7 millions de
visiteurs se sont rendus sur place en
2017 alors c'est le deuxième site le
plus visité en ile de france derrière le
musée du louvre devant la tour eiffel
alors on ne compte pas dans ce
classement 1 disneyland qui n'a pas
fourni ces derniers chiffres les
yvelines on peut le dire elodie bassesse
et c'est l'une des locomotives du
tourisme en ile de france
en effet on peut on peut le dire c'est
les yvelines sans le poumon vert de
l'île de france
on y vient aussi bien pour faire du
tourisme vert que pour découvrir ses
châteaux ses musées et tous ses sites à
visiter la tendance est plutôt bonne
dans les yvelines également
on
on a un petit peu moins de visiteurs que
sur l'ensemble du département on est on
est on est innocent peu moins rapide on
est à 5% d'augmentation par rapport aux
années précédentes mais on remarque
vraiment un retour des touristes
étrangers à un retour de la confiance
des visiteurs franciliens également
qu'ils sont très nombreux dans notre
département et notre souhait nous
désormais ça serait qu'il qu'il séjourne
encore plus dans le département qu'ils
viennent pas seulement au château de
versailles mais qu'il se diffuse sur
l'ensemble du département alors on va
avoir l'occasion d'en reparler
vous disiez à plus 5% d'arriver sur sur
territoire dans + 5 % de nuitées
hôtelières sur le le territoire on parle
finalement d'une bonne année on va pas
dire une année record pour les yvelines
mais c'est une bonne année en matière de
tourisme une année record parce que 2014
restera l'année record mais c'est une
année qui restera référence en matière
de tourisme
par rapport aux années précédentes qui
ont connu tous les mauvaises choses
qu'on a pu le voir et qui ont engendré
des des retours négatifs comme les
attentats les intempéries les crues etc
et les mouvements sociaux qu'on a connue
en 2016 2017 est une bonne année pour
l'hôtellerie et pour les sites
touristiques qui ont pour la grande
grande majorité connu beaucoup plus de
visiteurs bat sedan dans leurs sites web
si vous l'avez dit 2017 ça fait suite à
une année 2016 catastrophique
la menace terroriste vous avez également
parlé des décrues un des épisodes
météorologiques
ça explique qu'il ya une reprise aussi
cette année ça ça fait suite à une année
catastrophique finalement 2017 we will
et les chiffres étaient très mauvais en
surtout pour la fréquentation étrangère
mais mais également pour les franciliens
qui n'osaient plus se déplacer
finalement en ile de france
l'été avait été catastrophique il y
avait eu décrue au mois de juin cette
année
mais bien que l'été ne fut pas
exceptionnel on a vraiment une très
bonne fréquentation dans l'ensemble des
sites touristiques et comment
l'expliquer
votre avis c'est cette embellie ce
renouveau du tourisme en 2010 est une
volonté de nombreux événements également
des nouveautés des réouvertures on a le
château de rambouillet qui a réouvert en
septembre dernier le château de
versailles qui a toujours ses grandes
eaux nocturnes mais qui a lancé
également des événements sur la période
hivernale c'était une grande nouveauté
et ça a fait revenir beaucoup de
franciliens également au château de
versailles
on a des nouveautés à france miniature
avec les activités autour de fort boyard
des nouveautés au château de thoiry
enfin au parc zoologique de thoiry avec
une tyrolienne d'accord en fait tous les
sites essaye sans cesse de se renouveler
et on voit qu'en 2017 ce afin de bien
fonctionner l'ajustement si on regarde
le top 10 des sites les plus visités
dans les yvelines on voit bien sur le
domaine du château de versailles vous
avez parlé de france miniature deal de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
également le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines vient
d'envoyer une diversité de possibilités
aussi bien des sorties culturelles des
sorties loisirs nature c'est ça aussi la
force du territoire des yvelines
complètement nous
on souhaite vraiment que le département
soit reconnue comme une véritable
destination touristique qui dispose de
plusieurs entités et de plusieurs
territoires complètement complémentaires
on peut voir plein de choses dans les
yvelines on a et on a un territoire qui
est très campagne on a une offre muséal
et patrimonial qui est très très riche
on a également des bords de seine qui
sont une grande offre à valoriser qui
était le terrain préféré des
impressionnistes on peut aussi déambuler
dans des villes historiques et
patrimoniales on peut aller dans les
fermes pédagogiques à rencontre des
agriculteurs des goûters de très bons
produits locaux et on peut également
faire du vélo dans les yvelines
c'est un une action on met vraiment en
avant au sein du département des balades
en vélo possible on va peut-être
d'ailleurs voir l'acteur de vous avez
publié votre carte touristique de 2018
voilà on la voit elle est disponible au
sein du département est également très
prochainement dans tous les offices de
tourisme du département et on y valorise
les grands itinéraires pédestres et les
grands itinéraires cyclables pense qu'on
en a trois grands en construction et
deux qui sont bien implantés et qui nous
permet de traverser le département
rejoindre le mont saint-michel rejoindre
londres et bientôt rejoindre le havre en
passant par les yvelines vous y ayez un
mot sur sa tout à l'heure la clientèle
étrangère qui revient en 2017 dans les
yvelines c'est une tendance aussi à
noter oui oui elle elle revient
on voit + 34 % de chinois ils étaient
complètes il avait disparu avec les
attentats ils reviennent vraiment les
belges reviennent les allemands
également et on s'étonne un petit peu là
pour plus grande progression revient au
suisse d'accord avec qui qui reviennent
également dans les yvelines avec + 36 %
juste avant les chinois alors vous
disiez ces beaux chiffres pour le
tourisme en 2017 ils se sont dus à une
volonté quelle politique justement et
est mené par le département des yvelines
en matière de tourisme
est-ce qu'il faut noter alors en effet
le département a souhaité réintégrer
l'ancien comité départemental du
tourisme des yvelines et il s'est lancé
dans une politique de renouvellement et
de développement de l'offre touristique
via des missions d'ingénierie de conseil
et d'accompagnement des porteurs de
projets et des professionnels sur le
territoire
on est vraiment sur une nouvelle
politique qui souhaitent améliorer
l'offre et en développer une nouvelle
également pour paresser sur nos acquis
et pour justement développer toujours
cette fréquentation touristique un mot
peut-être sur le rapprochement au civil
hauts-de-seine qui sont rapprochés se
rapprocher autant au sein d'un
établissement public interdépartemental
ya une politique commune en matière de
tourisme qui a été mise en place
qu'est ce qu'il faut retenir qu est ce
que ça permet cette cette politique
commune en effet une politique commune a
été votée en juin dernier
et ça nous permet de travailler mieux
ensemble sur des thématiques qui sont
communes comme le tourisme d'affaires en
effet nous dans les yvelines ont à la
différence des hauts-de-seine on peut
valoriser les deux les séminaires
ouverts tous les incentives dans l'est
dans les sites patrimoniaux et on se
complète bien avec le territoire des
hauts-de-seine sur ce sursaut sur cette
thématique là on souhaite également
former les professionnels et et on a eu
le même type de professionnels donc on
travaille ensemble sur la formation
professionnelle et sur la valorisation
de l'axé seine car la scène ne se limite
pas aux frontières des yvelines a juste
dernière chose si on arrive déjà à la
fin de cet entretien 2018 comment ça
s'annonce sur le territoire est-ce que
les perspectives sont bonnes et quels
sont les grands événements qu'il faut
retenir pour 2018 alors ça s'annonce
plutôt bien en 2000 en 2018 les
professionnels sont confiants nous au
sein du département on va lancer un
nouveau pass touristique également
c'est une grande nouveauté qui existait
déjà mais qui était très restreinte et
qu'on va élargir pour permettre aux
professionnels aux yvelinois et aux
touristes de découvrir encore mieux
l'offre cette année dans les yvelines
on va avoir une année très sportive
qu'on accueille la ryder cup bien sûr
les championnats de france
voilà à saint quentin en yvelines les
championnats de france de cyclisme à
mantes la jolie
on a le lancement du paris nice
également très bientôt pour la neuvième
année consécutive dans les yvelines
et on connaît déjà les sites
sélectionnés pour les jo qui vont
commencer à organiser des événements
on aura également un grand événement
impérial au domaine de rambouillet alors
plutôt sur la seconde partie de l'année
est sans cesse des festivals de grandes
expositions des visites théâtralisées
dans l'ensemble des sites touristiques
qui qu'ils cessent de sun de se
renouveler et tous ces événements bien
sûr vous pouvez les retrouver sur le
site tourisme yves ina.fr qui s'affiche
en bas de l'écran merci le lit c'est
d'avoir été avec nous merci beaucoup te
rappelles chargé de communication à la
mission tourisme du département d
zibeline
on revient sur l'essentiel de la semaine
la nouvelle a été rendue officielle hier
jeudi l'ensemble du grand paris express
sera réalisé confirmation du premier
ministre edouard philippe re la ligne à
18 verra donc bien le jour mais avec un
calendrier recalés s'il arrivait à
versailles a maintenu à 2030 est la
livraison du premier tronçon jusqu'au
plateau de saclay et elle retardées 2027
au plus tard et non plus 2024 en
attendant de nouvelles circulations en
site propre seront mises en place entre
massy et saint quentin en yvelines
le président de saint quentin en
yvelines justement jean michel fourgous
n'a pas à cacher sa déception après ces
annonces d'après lui et les retards de
livraison vont nuire au développement du
cluster paris saclay il était l invité
du 7-8 journal hier jeudi 22 février
nous demain
j'entends que les mains aujourd'hui
disent bien écouté puisque c'est comme
ça moi je vous invite à construire les
logements qui étaient ou non je m'étais
engagé puisque si j'ai pas la gare à
proximité
certes son bazou un projet dont donc et
puis le développement de paris ckac et
quand même la silicon valley à la
française dont vraiment ce pays a besoin
c'est à dire de 2,2 de préparer des
pôles d'hyper l'hypercroissance qui vont
certainement sauver de ce pays puisque
voilà c'est il faut il faut déposer des
brevets il faut c'est comme ça que
demain le pays va serait enrichi ray un
pouvoir garantir les retraites
aie aie aie aie aie aie aie vous
financez bien sûr tous ces grands
projets vous aurez n'ont pas touché à
ses grands projets structurants de
l'intelligence française du talent
français de l'excellence française
surtout pas toucher à cela en ce moment
à la ligne 18 qui a fait à beaucoup
parler d'elle ces dernières années et
est même un temps évoquée la possibilité
d'avoir deux gars sur le territoire de
saint quentin en yvelines
le passage également en souterrain
envisagé du côté de
voisins-le-bretonneux retour dans le
passé dans nos archives avec nicolas
kirillovitch l'on passe pour l'instant
on fait du jour le grand paris express
le verdict est tombé en 2013 déjà la
rédaction de tv 60,18 faisait sa une sur
le grand paris express
à l'époque ne dit pas ligne 18 mai ligne
verte la clape
les réseaux de transport et
particulièrement effectivement on parle
de ligne 18 à présent la femme une ligne
verte le projet rebaptisé nouveau grand
paris et si en 2013 la ligne verte ou
plutôt la ligne 18 comporte encore de
gare à saint quentin en yvelines
ce n'est plus tout à fait le cas fin
2014 à l'époque se pose aussi la
question du passage en souterrain ce qui
départ acté aujourd'hui c'est savoir
surfer de leiria et du souterrain et
surfer donc de gao une gamme le problème
c'est que l'enveloppé financière est
elle si j'ai finalement le schéma avec
une gare sera validée mais c'est alors
le tracé qui pose problème à voisins le
bretonneux on s'inquiète du passage de
la future ligne sous un quartier de la
ville
il ya beaucoup de maisons où il ya des
micropieux à 15 20 m de profondeur et
donc forcément les gens sont inquiets et
c'est logique sur le devenir de leur
maison si on creuse en dessous suite à
l'enquêté publique réalisée en 2016 la
société du grand paris re tiendra
finalement le passage près du golf
national à guyancourt
il validera aussi le passage en viaduc à
magny-les-hameaux une option que la
ville a toujours rejeté on va se
retrouver avec une technologie qui est
fait du tout noël qui est pas du tout
durable qui est pas du tout innovantes
c'est tout simplement la technologie des
années 80-90 du fameux projet météores
et dernier épisode en date pour la ligne
18 il y a quelques mois les élus de
saint quentin en yvelines se mobiliser
suite à des informations parues dans la
presse
nous avons des bruits qui arrive jusqu'à
nos oreilles comme quoi les
parlementaires et sonia pèserait auprès
du gouvernement pour revoir ces
choses-là dont nous faisons entendre
haut et fort que nous voulons cette
ligne 18 confirmés dans les yvelines en
2030 le futur de la ligne 18 pourrait
être encore bouleversée c'est l'histoire
qui nous l'enseignent reprise du
dialogue actes et entre la verrière et
saint quentin en yvelines le dossier
d'aménagement de la zone guarbecque
année et relancer ce projet urbain était
bloqué depuis plusieurs mois du fait de
son importance les nouvelles
orientations votées lors du dernier
un conseil d'agglomération permettront
la construction à terme de 1000
logements
certains élus restent tout de même
inquiets les précisions avec nicolas
kirillovitch une nouvelle version du
projet gare bécane après plusieurs mois
de blocage les élus de l'agglomération
et la vie de la verrière sont finalement
parvenus à un accord pour relancer le
projet principale nouveauté la
construction de 1000 logements contre
1800 initialement quand vous avez un
trop gros projets de densification ça
des effets bien sûr sur les autres
communes dont qui a eu des échanges
jusqu'à modifier faire évoluer le projet
donc c'était le cas de ce soir c'est nos
objectifs qu'on a gardé comme un con
qu'on re défini autrement mais ce sont
les mêmes objectifs
parce que c'est important d'avoir on a
été élu sur un programme on n'a pas été
aidé sur un autre programme adopté en
conseil communautaire les nouvelles
orientations du projet ont suscité de
vives discussions entre les élus et je
rappelle que le seul axe structurant
route de la zac du week-end ce sera la
départementale 13 ans cinq des six
conseillers communautaires de maurepas
se sont abstenus pour cette délibération
inquiets notamment des répercussions
d'un tel projet pour leur ville je
m'inquiète en tant que maire de maurepas
sur les impacts qu'auront ces
aménagements sur la ville dans le futur
et comment les nouveaux habitants
vont-ils circuler dans cette nouvelle
zac et aux alentours
je j'entends les craintes d'impact que
ça peut avoir mais à travailler il n'y a
pas de nom solution au problème
la nouvelle évolution du programme
urbain entraîne une reprise des études
du projet celui ci devrait permettre
d'établir une part de logements sociaux
à hauteur de 25%
aucun calendrier en revanche n'est
encore fixée pour le début des travaux
c'est en ce moment les vacances d'hiver
une première semaine de congé qui a été
l'occasion pour des jeunes de
voisins-le-bretonneux de créer des
sculptures et ceux à base de matériel
recyclé des jouets et des pieds de
micros ou même des panneaux de
signalisation ont été utilisés un
atelier mené par une artiste vie
chinoise et qui s'inscrit dans la
démarche de développement durable menées
par la commune et mélanie poquet et
quentin le frère
soudés coupé cloué une dizaine de jeunes
vies sinois créés dans les ateliers de
la ville comme clara et anaïs 11 ans
clic construisent une horloge j'aime
bien dessiner du coup on a dû céder leur
place et j'ai du bon ok j'y vais pour
dessiner c'est totalement différent mais
ça m'a beaucoup plu ces désirs que par
exemple des touches de clavier ça peut
se retrouver en personnages en france et
donner une nouvelle vie aux objets passé
c'est bien elle fondu récup art de l'art
avec des objets de récupération
un atelier pensé par la commune et le
conseil municipal des jeunes avec l'aide
du service jeunesse de claire binet et
plus bas de tous les services municipaux
qui ont joué le jeu on a récupéré à la
déchetterie auprès des services aux
fonds au fond de son garage dans un
grenier dans une cave
tous les objets qui étaient destinés à
être mis donc à la déchetterie nous
sommes déjà là la ville de
l'agglomération qui est la meilleure
élève en terme de tri puisque nous avons
des taux d'erreur de trier les plus bas
et des taux de collecte de déchets
recyclables comme le verre ou des les
emballages les plus hauts de
l'agglomération elle les créations
seront exposées lors du salon imagina
dès le 7 avril
le week-end dernier se tenait la
deuxième édition de la coupe de danse de
danse sportive à versailles c'était à
versailles des centaines de danseurs
s'étaient donné rendez-vous dont quatre
membres d'une même famille elle les
parents et leurs enfants ils ont débuté
il ya seulement trois ans la danse mais
c'est devenu aujourd'hui une passion
rencontre signée mélanie poké et patrick
jacques de dixmude
tarik birgit tara il ya quatre membres
d'une même famille et le même passion la
danse
une découverte toute nouvelle pour eux
leurs premiers pas de danse sportive
il est fort il ya seulement trois ans
j'ai tout d'abord fait des sports tél le
rugby ou le football je me passais par
le handball
et puis ensuite j'ai décidé de
développer beaucoup plus mon côté
artistique et donc nous voilà et je dois
dire que je préfère dix fois le côté
artistique au côté brut ou au côté très
physique du handball bien sûr la danse
est un sport physique aussi mais dans un
autre sens c'est plus de la
concentration
ce qui me plaît avant tout c'est des
moments qu'on passe ensemble c'est
vraiment une activité familiale donc un
partage très fort on partage beaucoup de
choses beaucoup de plaisir beaucoup de
passion parfois un peu d'énervement
aussi c'est voilà c'est mais c'est avant
tout un moment un moment à passer
ensemble une passion devenue dévorante
birgit et la présidente de leur club
le duo dance club de colombes tarik en
est le vice président ils pratiquent
tous les quatre les danses standards et
latines
[Musique]
nous dans la famille pour l'instant
on aime vraiment les les deux ont donc
on aime les dix danses dans les
standards et latines et pour l'instant
on n'a fait aucun choix
il est probable avec l'âge en général
que les seniors en libéral à un moment
se concentre plus sur les dons standard
que ce soit les danses latines
si tarik et bien qu'ils sont en couple
tard haye wiam son frère et soeur un
avantage pour eux les avantage c'est
qu'on peut se voir tout le temps on a
forcément on est plus familier l'un avec
l'autre plus il ya moins de chaînes de
poser les mains quelque part que si
c'était quelqu'un qu'on connaissait pas
bon après on parle bien sûr on dit des
choses bien plus naturellement parfois
des choses d'exemple l'un à l'autre
parce que forcément se connaît mieux
mais sinon être rsr c'est vraiment c'est
vraiment extraordinaire
ce dimanche il participait à une épreuve
qualificative de coupe de france
tahar rayane ont terminé deuxième du
concours de danses standards et vise
l'international
[Musique]
la coupe de france de danse sportive
donc c'était le week-end dernier à
versailles allez on referme cette
émission sur une fête déjantée bruit de
moteur et odeur de gasoil ont envahi le
vélodrome national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines c'était la
huitième édition de la butte âge party
une soirée folle mêlant course de moto
et concerts retour avec mélanie poker je
suis un soir parce que la lumière quand
je suis rentré et de la lumière il y en
avait pour 7 buts edge parti vendredi
soir le vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines avait pris des
allures de circuits moto on permet aux
gens d'un petit peu lâcher prise mais
toujours dans le temps dans un espèce de
journée on est tous des sportifs de
sports extrêmes
on gère à notre manière les risques y a
pas vraiment beaucoup de risques parce
que la piste va pas très vite et tout ça
donc on essaye de canaliser les gens
dans un bordel ambiance années 60 70 ou
presque et la beach party c'est simple
un dress code du sport un concert et une
absence totale de sérieux que je suis un
prix nobel de débilité et entre prix
nobel on se comprend et on s'est tous
rejoint ici ce soir est super bonne
ambiance et voilà c'est gentillet et
s'écoule à tarbes roman
super il ya de l'ambiance de belles
images c'est top
à saint quentin en yvelines c'était la
huitième du teich partie mais la
première en ile de france près de 250
buteurs sont venus s'affronter des
pilotes qui n'ont pas froid aux yeux
mais mme allen ou encore dix ans
[Musique]
c'est la fin de cette émission à suivre
le 7-8 loisirs de à camille lambert pour
avoir toutes les idées de sorties du
week-end le 7-8 l'hebdo et à lui est
quant à lui à revoir sur notre site
internet et notre application mobile atv
78 retour de l'information dès lundi 18h
en direct sur tv 78 excellent week end à
tous
[Musique]